most projects that come in most of them
I turned down I don't know if it's fear
but it's certainly insecurity it uses me
that one is nominated for an Oscar an
amount of woman sat there knitting
during our audition yeah and another
person was sort of looking at papers
sort of smoking the cigarette and I and
I finished my audition and they just
said well you know think about something
else to do for a living
need motivation watch a top ten would
believe nation what's up but seven my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see exploded
onto the world so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
in today's lessons from a man who went
from being abandoned by his alcoholic
father at age seven to dropping out of
school age sixteen to work in a Sport
Shop to becoming an Oscar award-winning
actor he's Gary Oldman and here's my
take on his top ten rules of success
enjoy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one step out onto the wire how
did you get your head around playing
right Winston Churchill Winston
Churchill what like most most projects
that come in most of them I turned down
initially only because I think it's out
of I don't know if it's fear but it's
certainly insecurity even still yeah
nearly 60 and doing it 40 years and I
say to myself why they should get
someone else yeah you know and it's
nearly always happened with the things
that have been the most challenging the
most rewarding and the most successful
yeah yeah I had the same week right and
you could even turn them down more than
once and they seemed to wash back up on
the shore and they won't take no for an
answer and then you then you have to
sort of collect and you know thinking
okay let me think about this so you're
that you're being asked to play
obviously I have a striking resemblance
to Churchill clearly it's obviously I
mean you must have been related in a
past life so it gave me great pause to
think this is ridiculous I don't look
anything like him
it it it's an incredible role yeah it's
the role of a lifetime it's like four
star for yeah being offered the King
Lear
but sorry I'm not going I'm not going to
do it it was my my dear my dear friend
Douglas and and my wife who said come on
you're gonna stand in Parliament and
you're gonna say blood toil tears and
sweat we should fight the mother but you
know really you'd and I thought what's
the worst that could happen hmm I'd be
off I'd get over it way to move on
their lives you know this is not sort of
like so I said yes and of course the
moment that you step out onto the wire
yeah yeah you're looking at the drop
below you and then to end and and and
then thus it began rule number two be
prepared when I arrived on the set I've
done my homework and I'm ready to work
and I've noticed occasionally there are
people that think they get they're a
little lazy and that they can wing it
and you've got to be incredibly talented
to be able to wing it
you know but that would be that would be
my advice to people just be early I'm
ready to work rule number three live in
the real world my career has been I've
worked out of necessity I've worked on
things that that I would have preferred
not to work on but I need to you've got
to live in the real world and you have
kids and responsibilities and and paying
bills like everybody else when you're
young when you're when I was 20 when I
was 20 and I was not a care in the world
you know it can I would I was I just was
had such a fixity of purpose and I
wouldn't compromise and and but you can
falter when you don't have those other
responsibilities when you're when you're
a grown-up and you're in the real world
you've you've got a you know so it's
it's taken me I've not always I thought
I've not always been completely in
control of the reins of the career and
occasionally there have been times when
when I can when I can direct it and then
steer it rule number four be creative
I'm still a mystery to you but I know
exactly what your white ass is coming
from see by X if you want some dinner
can you quit the everyone started tried
a little myself this he's camping out
like he ain't got a care in the world
and who knows maybe he don't maybe this
fools
such a bad you don't got to worry about
nothing he just sit down in TV see you
ain't even sat down yet
and a TV over there since you've been in
the room as a woman with a breasteses
hanging out you mean even bothered to
look you just been clacking me
[Music]
and I'm pretty but I ain't as pretty as
a couple of kids
we were shooting Romeo in New York and I
was late one night in the Bronx was in
the trailer and I heard a couple of kids
outside walking past and I heard this
voice and I said that's the voice for
Drexel and so I got the kid in caught
him off the street and I said would you
do me a favor I said would you would you
record your voice for me and I said
would you read these scenes and you tell
me what lines don't work and then he
read them and he went through the script
and he went yeah me he said that don't
fly do another thing I was ki was
changing the script rule number five
find your moment of clarity when did you
first realize you were interested in
acting I saw a movie I was at home one
evening and there was a preview came up
on the on the TV and it was a Brian
Ford's movie with Malcolm McDowell and
it called that called the raging moon
but it may have been caught something
else here it may not stand the test of
time I have not seen it for 30-something
years
but I Malcolm McDowell came on and it
was it was like him as alcoholics call
it at a moment of clarity I had a moment
of clarity it was like a light going on
and I thought III want to do that rule
number six my personal favorite that I'm
gonna be sharing with Alex and Lily who
I'm mentoring is follow the feeling
wherever the cost may be
please recite all the BCS please
and recall once hearing you saying that
acting is not intellectual it's feeling
how do you get to that point of feeling
your character the only way I could
describe it is you're looking for for
instance the way he sounds and if you
listen to the voice and you listen to
the speech his assistant and that's what
I start and that's why I started with he
has this slight speech impediment and
there's a lisp
Judah's the sound that he makes and it
comes right the new pier that also comes
down the nose and he's got this sort of
thing and he had this sort of thing he
did with his mouth and his lip so you're
trying to capture that sensation in in
the in the mouth in the in the in the
sound and that's what I mean by feeling
it rather than you can't read a book
that could give you that you you that
that you haven't you have to work and
find it through a sensation and that's
the thing you're trying to sort of
capture so it becomes less about
intellect or more about what you're what
you're feeling rule number seven love
the process I'm technically out of work
at the moment and I mean then that's
something that you that you must see you
swimming you know you're very I'm very
used to that and that to me is it
Muse's me that one is nominated for an
Oscar animal
you know but I don't going wait a table
can I you know it would not it not right
now I'm enjoying it though I think
you've got a you have to embrace it and
surrender to it and not and enjoy I
think you have to remember to enjoy it
rule number eight prove them wrong now
is it true that you apply to but were
turned down by the Royal Academy of
Dramatic Art yes I was Alec Guinness
Laurence Olivier although you know all
those all those guys that one sort of
looked up to they had all had this
career that sort of started with the
Royal Academy so it was an obvious place
for me to to go to you know and and I
found them that very rude of woman sat
there knitting during the audition yeah
and another person was sort of looking
at papers sort of smoking the cigarette
and I and I finished my audition and
they just said well you know think about
something else to do for a living do you
have anything to fall back on
and but so that was it that was it I was
a blow yeah they put it was a blow but i
but i but i dusted myself off and you
know went for it and i've got into
another school and and and have now
learned that they aren't sort of much of
a muchness I mean you just take you
leave the bad take the good and and it's
about your it's about your own
commitment it's about application really
more than more of course there are great
teachers but but I I went and I work
I've worked very hard and was the first
was the was the first in my year to get
to get a job to get an equity card but
that wasn't I don't it wasn't because I
was the the most talented guy there I
just I've worked very hard I wrote the
letters I had but my picture take and
everybody else was was kind of you know
and around about the pub and I was sort
of doing I was sort of doing the work
and taking it seriously rule number nine
be fully immersed in your craft here's
the odd thing
despite the prosthetics and you know the
the whole getup
it was the most relaxed and the most
free I've ever been
it it it once I don't mean listen I
don't mean it in an arrogant way but
once I had done the work and I felt that
I had found him it was like breathing
but I but I do look at the I do look at
the piece and and and some moments I
hope really I didn't pre conceived
anything
like I don't remember doing them I mean
and I I hadn't oh I had just a little a
little under a year to prep to prep him
and so all those the way he would turn
his papers and the way he would hold his
hand and sort of gestures and things
like that became so part of it that I
didn't have to think about it I wasn't I
didn't have to consciously remind myself
you were just in it I could just be in
it and that was very that was a very
freeing thing and rule number ten the
last one before the bonus clips tell
great stories
I did a Air Force One with Harrison Ford
and we were on a set which was obviously
the aircraft of Air Force One there were
signs everywhere there was no drinking
no smoking and no eating on the set and
there was one day when I looked around
and Harrison was standing in the doorway
beneath the sign that said no smoking no
drinking and no eating and he was
drinking a coffee eating a burrito while
smoking a cigar and he was doing all
three
now I've got two very special gary
oldman bonus clips around getting it in
your blood and learning to express
yourself but before that I want to get
to the commitment of the day you watch
this video don't just watch another
video what did you learn from this and
how are you going to commit to doing
something better in your life or in your
business leave it down the comments
below make it public so we can hold you
accountable thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
I'll see you soon and enjoy the bonus
clips
with Winston I had it was a unique
experience because it was 10 11 months
that I could work on it I was thinking
about it for over a year we had four
weeks rehearsal so you actually got to
physicalize and vocalize the character
with the people that you're going to be
doing it with and now I knew that I was
off-book I knew the whole screen yeah I
knew the whole script like a play before
I got there because it isn't stuff that
you can you can't think about it you
have to kind of know it so well I'm a
big believer it's not how well you know
something it's how long you've known it
because then it's like part years of
blood it's your DNA and then you have it
you have it instantly it's instant
recall nil by mouth is an emotional well
that I have been drawing on for years so
people say to me how long did it take to
write and I say it took six weeks but it
was 30 years in development you know I
you know you it's it has to cut a
character once you've got all those pick
though all those pieces that I was
talking about then you have to filter
them through your own particular prism
they then have to then make then they
could then they they live through you I
don't I don't express myself with with a
piano or a violin I mean you know the
instrument and so if you see Dracula
crying that's Gary crime
so you're drawing on all that staff and
that's so I've been using I've been
using nil by mouth in a way that all of
that for all those years in in in the
acting the most important work ever if
you had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be like a little beacon pay
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details
[Music]